it was just so awkward because I would
be standing there and then I'd just go
every single time but you did a good job
really well the most appropriate time to
use VFX would be for a magical film but
for Netflix is the school for good and
evil the magic was made in real time so
let's fly into some of the ways
production produced this epic tale and
how they managed to pull off the huge
Evers ball fight with this fiery behind
the scenes look number one we have
always wondered how this scene would
have turned out if it was a neversfall
the Evers ball fight scene was so
massive to plan and execute with the
dozens of actors and stun performers
flying through the air it sort of looked
like everyone was just running around
here every time you see someone flying
that's usually a real person on some
sort of rig but with the amount of
flying stunts and Pyro effects stunt
coordinators needed to make sure all
persons involved were safe and of course
knew what they were doing Sophia Wiley
and Sophia and Caruso had such a tough
time delivering their dialogue that they
were forced to come back into a
voiceover Studio to dump their lines in
the sound of these Flames like yeah so
we're trying to focus with the sound of
this fire and then had to go back in
later
typically for films this doesn't come to
a surprise but they were not really
looking forward to that part of the
fight scene can we just say though those
crew members working the pulley systems
really deserve Oscars for their work
number two notice how there are barely
any blue or green screens on set well
that was all by Design when director
Paul feig put this massive production
together they crafted each individual
set from the words of the original book
by author solman shinani everything was
filmed on practical locations and sound
stages in Northern Ireland by keeping
these things on set as real as possible
this not only makes it look great in the
Final Cut but it also creates a better
acting atmosphere for the cast a lot of
it was just real so that it looked real
for us to act with it believing in the
performances makes us believe in the
magic number three let's face it we were
all a little creeped out by Sophie's
witch Prosthetics it was it was funny
some people didn't want to look at me
like some cast members are like I can't
look at you like this poor Wiley was
forever scared by Caruso's new look that
she started crying Caruso unfortunately
didn't stop scaring people after that
though she actually made Michelle yo
jump out of her skin a little I want to
do it again it was so fun number four
while the majority of the school for
good and evil was practically done you
still need to add a few touches of VFX
to make the Spells pop even when digital
effects were added however they still
use practical effects to beef up the end
results the magical finger spells were a
lot of what the characters used they
were made by placing a light at the end
of their fingers we had like a
prosthetic finger that looked really
weird it was like a very huge E.T moment
this made for a pretty visual experience
for the audience and quite an enjoyable
time for the guest the fire effects
however were not so enjoyable
particularly with the fire in the effers
ball fight scene roaring over everyone's
hearing number five again these stunned
people deserve all the recognition in
the world for their work here this looks
so rough we're not sure whether the
camera movements made these look tougher
than they were but wow we don't think
those mats made such a big difference
for them and safety measures only go so
far before someone starts getting
Whiplash
ouch number six we've always wondered
what it'd be like to be a costume
designer for a Blockbuster movie
according to costume designer Renee
Ehrlich kaufus it is not as carefree as
many would think by the time she was
done creating the almost endless supply
of outfits and accessories she was
extremely exhausted she may have gone a
little off for Rocker with this one
saying we did almost 1 000 custom-made
costumes plus 750 boots shoes and pieces
of jewelry I can't even tell you about
it all we made everything
number seven no thank you we will not be
picking a fight with Jamie flatters
anytime soon you can really tell that a
lot of the actors in this movie put in
the work to do their own stunts even
though it kind of looks like Jaime will
need a few hours to recover from this
sparring session but hey if he knows
what he's doing here we're positive he
can pull off all the complex moves
Tedros can do number eight here's a
challenge question for all of you how
many rehearsals do you think it took for
these boys to get this right seriously
though we would like to know we would
guess more than a few times for sure and
anytime actors have to wave swords
around uniformly is super exhausting but
the way it turned out in the end
incredible we laugh at the thought of
that one person messing it up at the end
though we would definitely be that
person number nine the easiest way to
get through an elegant Walt scene is to
just bring in the professionals these
professionals were the Irish dancing
group karda and let's just say they made
this look brutally easy they even got to
X exercise their own acting jobs do and
perform a few times to ease the stress
of the other cast members number 10
we're sure any naysayers out there can
agree that this scene was pretty Rad but
what was even more rather about this
fight sequence was the stunt rehearsal
and luckily for us they filmed it now
since these movements required a lot of
leaps and punching we can only wish more
of this was in the Final Cut they really
proved to us time and time again that
they can just make these moves Look So
Easy number 11 who doesn't love the idea
of wearing a corset for work every day
just kidding we think Sophia and Caruso
would destroy us for that one I think
you had the worst with the corsets every
outfit the best poor Caruso was quite
literally just not allowed to take a
deep breath during her scenes why well
because her character just called for a
lot of dresses of course some of the
other leading ladies wore corsets but
only for a couple of outfits I can't
green I liked it
Sophia recalls these horrible dress
accessories as being the hardest thing
to put on every morning and very
detrimental for the costume dresser's
hands the other Sofia took a lot of deep
size of relief when her character wasn't
dressed to suffocate for the work day
but was this very Sophie she would have
you know it would be cinched to the gods
number 12. Hester was incredibly hard to
cast as her character's personality was
so unique to anything anyone's ever seen
casting director Fiona Ware had to sort
through thousands of actresses and
ultimately landed upon the devilishly
evil Freya Parks Hester has a very
specific kind of energy that which made
it hard for us to find the Hester
oh I know we got it with approval by
Suman Freya was just the only person in
the world right for this part number 13.
the coven Clan really made a real-life
best decline as soon as they met each
other because actresses Freya Parks Demi
Isaac of Hawaii and Caitlyn Atkin
bellumi heated off so well in real life
they passed those chemistry reads with
flying colors they're just so perfectly
evil together it's almost like we look
at Jennifer and go here we are we happy
each other number 14 apparently Sophia
and Caruso is the queen of auditioning
according to Sophia Wiley you were so
calm and collected and you just knew
that you had it because she is Sophie
Caruso was so confident in her audition
that she fooled widely during the
process not only did this make Wiley a
little nervous but also allowed her to
really feed off the high energy Caruso
is making on screen now why controller
I've got this I think I think Sophie's
kind of got that too she's like excuse
me this is my world her role in
particular was another hard one to cast
but after another lengthy search around
the world she just knocked the
broomsticks out from under the casting
Department the evil is certainly strong
with this one number 15. we could never
imagine how Salman felt when he was
approached about making his tail into a
film to me it's such a part of my soul
so I never even conceived of the
possibility that it would become real it
took him over 10 years to develop the
book so we can understand how wonderful
he felt when he realized it was such a
big deal to Millions around the world
you have to constantly wake yourself up
from this like living dream you're
having there were a whole lot of magical
and practical things going on here
behind the scenes thank goodness
everyone came out of here limbs intact
so are you a never or an ever let us
know in the comments